[Applause]
oh
it's it's been a crazy day D oh my God a
crazy week yeah what's going on you guys
this is this is gaming addict Lord
addict here coming at you with another
addict show that the show where we talk
about the past present future gameing I
got my co-host with me DT griggy what's
going on
D and these dudes still want to say Xbox
is going to be gone by
2027 worry about your own
house it's it's like I said man people
people sitting
there they they they
attacking all this this
publicity and it's like maybe if you
would have worried about your own your
own lane and stop talking about my Lane
yep your house wouldn't be on fire right
now you guys read the title it's going
to be a very messy show the very messy
show we got a little bit of little stuff
to talk about uh but we are going to
definitely build up to what's going on
right now at PlayStation uh first topic
that you know I want to talk about after
we talk about what is what what what
what what are we playing what what are
you playing here recently
Dirk I am playing Allan way too my man I
I completely abandoned that game me and
alen wake that's not happening yeah so
how you feel alen white I have some
thoughts um first off I love the first
one I loved it and this one is
completely
different um the first one was more of
an action horror game this one is a
survival horror game 100% uh it's you
know there now I rather enjoy uh a saga
Anderson Parts part so far Allan Wake
part is a little slow it's a little slow
but I'm starting to get into it um I
like the game but I'm still I'm still
kind of early I'm just at Allan Way park
in the subway um so yeah it's a little
slow his part is a little slow to me
because you know I'm still trying to
think this is Allen Wick but it's not
Allen Wick it's a totally new survival
horror game but it's uh cool so I'm
definitely GNA finish it
though yeah I I've been playing a lot of
persona right now I'm on Persona 4 I
have finally finished Persona 5
completely M and uh you know I'm very
curious uh what they're going to do next
with the
franchise and uh you know what I want to
talk about first going into this and I
want your overall opinion let me get the
Super Chat real quick you got a $5 Super
Chat from dawn uh Nintendo Don diaku
after faking Spider-Man 2 C
so did you see that did you see that
please tell me you saw that oh man yeah
apparently they miscount how do you
miscount oh man yeah I did see that you
know in the in the UK or whatever um
yeah how do you just
miscount I don't know I don't know but
um Donna taku was funny
man the T D Taco was hilarious that was
funny what's funny is normally uh
normally you and Donna talk when we
going at it but no that's not talking
about Nintendo like besides
that look man today today we we we're
gonna have some serious conversations
today we're gonna we're gonna throw some
jokes out there uh first thing we're GNA
talk about is grounded you know grounded
just got a serious update you know
pretty much a a forge mode if you will
yeah that's cool they they got some
other little updates and what I want to
go in with grounded is you know I made a
video about it today it's it's
ironic that even though Xbox is in third
place they have literally dictated the
entire gaming industry no one was doing
games as a service really besides EA
then Xbox makes game pass it you know
triumphs over over EA play oh that's
what it's called now it was called EA
access and then Sony decided they need
to do it uh they they even bought an
entire company to help them do that and
what what what I find interesting and
intriguing is Jim Ryan was over there
looking at se thieves over there looking
at Fallout
76 over there looking at Elder Scrolls
Online speak on it over there looking at
Minecraft well well and was like I want
that I want that exactly and he rised
his whole
company to do that someone he said I
didn't read his whole Super Chat what
you mean I didn't read your whole Super
Chat what he said uh so I'll read the
whole Super Chat he said okay after F oh
I'm sorry I'm
sorry we were laughing so much we the
first sentence we were laughing because
he was it was funny after faking
Spider-Man 2 sale Sony realized they
didn't actually hit their target they
fire and and Insomniac dead for every
50,000 sales they missed oh my God man
that's
brutal oh yeah we
we that's brutal man we gonna get into
that look uh if you guys look I I have
updated the uh uh the the key notes for
the podcast the Keynotes for the show
we're gonna be talking about the
grounded update the Bungie layoffs the
Insomniac game layoffs and just
PlayStations on fire in general you know
what's funny last week one of my time
stamps was PlayStation on fire I just
let that that sucker there I didn't even
change it I was like PlayStation on fire
two weeks in a row hell PlayStation's
been on fire all year that could be
misinterpreted though because usually
when we say some's on fire that mean it
it's it's doing well no they they they
are definitely but they're definitely
not well they they they are
definitely hurting they're hurting yep
but that that that's okay
so what I I find hilarious and I can't
not get this camera where it needs to be
there we go what I find hilarious
is it feels like it feels like
Xbox and PlayStation's always had this
back and forth
thing but Jim Ryan especially you know
he was over there talking all that extra
stuff during that show and he just he
wanted nothing but to be Xbox he wanted
their games as a service he wanted their
uh their their
their streaming services in general
because he tried to mimic that [__] y he
has done everything in his power to
become Xbox in a way and what's funny is
how is number one gonna copy number
three to this degree I want your opinion
on
that I think the reason They're copying
because they see something that looks
like it's working even though Xbox is
third place as far as console sales go
and Market um share PlayStation say you
know what we need that we need that we
got got to have it listen you know I was
saying this you know even with Halo
infinite and I don't know if you seen
they said that um I just retweeted how
they said halo Infinite season five
numbers is the best it's been I believe
ever in like Halo infinite like I forgot
to even bring up halo infinite even Hal
infinite in in its in its hiccups and
it's and its stumbles PlayStation would
love to have a games in service like
that bro if you can if you drop a game
like CF these that came out in
2018 people are still playing this game
putting money into this game a game like
grounded came out when it come out
2021 people still you know they're still
updating the game new stuff that's what
PlayStation
wanted but the only thing Jim Ryan went
to nauy dog said yo I know you guys make
some of the best single player games of
all time I want you guys to do a games
at the service no you know then then he
tried to buy a studio like um Haven or
or or or fir walk then those guys are
trying to do their game and then Bungie
comes in and tell everybody nope nope
that's not it we don't like that that's
not good enough and the whole time
bunging [__] wasn't together so it's a
mess right now man it's a mess it's just
the part that just irritates me with
this whole PlayStation thing is just
just how I don't know if these
PlayStation people are are just in
denial or they're just
lying
like you go back couple years and I
think you can agree with this Dirk you
could clearly see the crumb
there were such big crumbs that King was
eating that [__] for
years it it was it was clear it was
clear that PlayStation was on
fire but they only wanted you to see the
waiting room you know it's so one of
those things where if you go into the
next room it's nothing but like
everything has been ripped out there's
no there's no Foundation it's like it's
like it's like looking at a Hollywood
set where it's nice in the front when
you go in the back they ain't nothing
there and for years you know we've been
told you know why don't you call out
Xbox why don't you do this why don't you
do that and we have we've got stuff
reversed like Xbox Live going gold uh
the the price increase well it wasn't
necessarily a price increase it was just
them stopped giving you the ability to
pay a whole year up front it there was
so many things that we did come out
there and we spoke against and a lot of
that got reversed but where was where
was where was kings hold the line
movement on
Playstation where where was we want
better and part of me feels like it's
gotten so bad and maybe maybe it's just
me but I feel like
certain influencers now only say stuff
because they want to say later on down
the line here's all here is moments and
here's
times where I have spoke
out I do spook speak out I I think a lot
of people are scared half to death of
being labeled a corporate shell or
whatever these people trying to say
these now or a fanboy or whatever people
use these narratives that they just like
dude I just I'm about gaming yeah and
it's like I I call a rock a rock and
people have been throwing rocks through
the PlayStation windows for years and no
one says anything nobody but listen yeah
the Littest stuff for Xbox you know what
I find it hilarious when I find it
crazy is all of this bad news for
PlayStation all the PlayStation podcast
are still talking about Xbox
100% I saw a clip of a podcast
I believe it was last
night they were asking they were talking
about the layoffs at Bungie the one guy
say got diverted Xbox to that's a that's
a nothing Burger it's nothing Xbox
Microsoft laid off 10,000 people earlier
this year and blah blah blah I said um
well you know Xbox just literally added
10,000 plus people to their
payroll right they just added that to
their payroll but they're still focusing
on that Xbox addict you said it you said
it when there were years when xBox
wasn't doing so
well there were people like me that I
would criticize Xbox and I remember
people uh said D I'm not watching your
channel anymore you know like me yes the
the D Grigg the
Xbox I was pissed off after E3 2019 this
guy said I'm quitting your channel I'm
like what am I like an ex-girlfriend or
something you quitting my channel what
the hell you mean but there were people
that just had so much fun during those
days where xBox wasn't doing so well but
now with PlayStation is it looking so
hot every instead of criticizing
PlayStation and being concerned about
what's happening with PlayStation these
guys try to pull up articles from Xbox
or Microsoft laying off people a year
ago or three weeks ago or two years ago
bringing up people names yeah but what
about when Shinji Mami left do you
notice what's going on with PlayStation
sir you're talking about uh a few
individuals here and there yes there's
layouts that happen everywhere but
there's so much stuff happened at
PlayStation at the same time you're
gonna just ignore that and focus on what
Xbox is doing no pay attention to what's
happening with PlayStation and it's like
yeah let's talk about what Xbox is doing
uh they have
been correcting the ship when it comes
to squar Enix yep they have been getting
better quality games games and Game Pass
they have been uh securing Activision
Blizzard King they have been updating
the
the the dashboard of Xbox a 100th time
for some reason I don't know why they
keep doing that you know they have been
evolving the brand now you can debate
on the games I get it but you look at
the Metacritic besides redfall the past
year like EX out of years it's been
almost nothing but 80 plus games for
like three years sure you might not like
Age of Empire or Psychonauts or
wasteline 3 or Forza even Halo infinite
got a 86 or an
87 what about the
games but you know what it is they're
not doing the games they want them to do
you know there is multiple ways to
compete than just competing the way way
your competitor
competes if Nintendo did everything the
way PlayStation well where is that
energy for Nintendo where is that energy
for where is that overthe
shoulder action-based narrative Focus
third person thing where is that when's
the last time you saw someone say why
doesn't Nintendo have more Last of Us
clones or you know even to my thing when
it comes to the the superhero thing they
did have that Marvel Ultimate Alliance
but they don't seem to get that energy
at all it's just Xbox
yeah you know what look man um even this
this guy in the chat
Nixie bro what do you want y'all talking
about PlayStation I know he's being
sarcastic
but you guys need to realize what's
going on man y' y'all y'all need to stop
worrying about what Xbox like adct just
broke it broke down what Xbox is doing
well right now hey Nixie you know I just
beat Spider-Man 2o right you know I
played you a gota explain nothing this I
play final no no no no no no no Nixie we
we gonna talk we're gonna talk sit sit
down N I just beat Persona 5 Royale that
that that debuted on Playstation have
you did that
next wh what about what up Spider-Man
you played that next
huh what about that what what what about
Final Fantasy 16 did you beat that I
didn't beat that but I'm willing to say
I didn't beat that huh did you be God of
War Ragnarok God of War 18 hold on hold
hold let say this I'm sorry this Nixie
both Brands yes no brand is perfect but
what's in the news right now
Nixie PlayStation PlayStation nobody's
talking about what happened two weeks
ago with Xbox and last time I checked
the atct show is a multi plat podcast it
is not an Xbox
podcast it is a multiplat podcast and so
so let me get this straight I don't hate
PlayStation first off Nixie
okay okay then we're both on the same
platform because I'm on PlayStation 2
hey D don't you own PlayStation 5
unfortunately you be acting like they be
acting
like there's like a a magical link that
shows up and you have to be invited to
it and you can't get this this platform
unless unless it comes from the heavens
and it just shows up and that's the only
way you could play a PlayStation 5 Nixie
you can go to a Walmart pick up a
PlayStation 5 you can play PlayStation 5
probably on on Facebook
Marketplace they're
everywhere stop it see see I think you
being nice though
Ed see because this see this the type of
dude that that's the uh ammunition for
my channel for my podcast you can't tell
me what to talk about you can't tell ad
what to talk about on his
channel you can't tell the on what to
talk about we talk about what they want
to so niie tell tell me what we should
talk about Xbox because we were just
talking about
grounded so yeah we're talking about gr
tell me what you think we should talk
about because I'm I'm curious he to
ignore the PlayStation that's that's
where I'm going with this I'm curious
what
Nixie wants us to talk first off what is
that on what is that as a profile
picture he has no is that such a
PlayStation someone look is that a
PlayStation thing see that's the thing
though see I'm I'm I'm highly annoyed by
people like n this isn't the iron Lords
podcast I will put you front in
Center I don't
care all right you tell me what we need
to talk about
Nixie tell me please tell me because I'm
curious what you think is more this is
the thing we were talking about the
biggest news in gaming right now
dirt all over X it's all over Twitter is
it our fault it's PlayStation nope
definitely not our
fault it's not our fault so Nixie I'm
waiting for you Nixie tell me what's
going on on
[Laughter]
Xbox I wish I had oh maybe he wants us
to do hour and a half podcast talk about
field experence with cooking pancakes
with Charity that's what he wants right
I I he want us to ignore all of the
PlayStation news talk about field experi
of cooking pancakes that's what you want
us to do yeah here's the thing I want
the industry to do better you know me
what's funny is where was Nixie when me
and dirt were going at it for an hour
and a half talking about whether or not
Xbox needed a a a a a superhero game
where were you then niie Mike Johnson
PlayStation is doing just fine you have
no concern Mike Johnson none at all
right oh my God Bungie apparently
Insomniac hey hey hey Mar fire Sprite
keep keep Nixie timed out keep nexie
timed out uh he he he has got enough of
uh what's wrong enough Center attention
see this arrogance is what what got
y'all in the situation y'all in right
now y'all thinking PlayStation is
Flawless like PlayStation does no wrong
only because they sell more consoles if
the console sells meant so damn much why
they L laying people off why are they
counseling games y'all dumb all of
you oh my god
let's like dumbass red dragon gonna say
nine to one uh Xbox uh being outsold
nine to one in
France at one retailer it can sell 20 to
one it still ain't the the the most hot
thing to talk about right now I guess
hezy I guess he wants to talk about
Starfield and how bad it is for for the
18 look look Johnson D PlayStation is
doing smart
things like if if XBox was laying off
people that wouldn't be smart then so
laying off like a vast majority of your
of of your developers that that's a
smart
thing this what I show you they never
criticized PlayStation at all never oh
you know what you know what they want us
to talk about DT what's that that
Quantum air game was lit oh Quantum air
yeah yeah Quantum air is the most
inative game I've ever played you know
when I'm playing this game I think I
pronounced it right I don't know I did
when I'm playing this game man I'm
smiling from ear to ear y this game is
so lit I stopped playing Spider-Man 24
you know that CPR yet did you do the
blow you could do CPR and you have to
blow into the controller yeah oh I got
it blow into the controller well that
might as well be CPR and the Knicks
because he's done okay I'm not blowing
in the controller to save you next it's
not happen
Quantum
era let's talk about Quantum actually
let's
really say y'all never criticize Field
Spencer people were saying fire Field
Spencer earlier this
year I wasn't but it was some other Xbox
guys here's the
thing oh my God blow that okay shut up
oh man here's the thing I'm not going to
sit here and demand a job I've always
said one I've always said and I think
you can agree
D I've waited so
long for these games that are coming out
and keep in mind they have delivered
good game just because they're not third
person over the shoulder action
adventure games does not mean they're
they're just tooken away you know
Wasteland three cyc knots three or two
or whichever which one is there's been a
countless and I think I think cyclonauts
was a 90 Plus game saiz was nominated
for game of the year so was so was the
outer worlds yeah it was and and people
are like but an these G these these
games the these these IPS they they're
not exclusive neither is
Destiny get them at neither neither is
Marathon this crazy is
like
like we've been to be
fair let's let's be
fair it's been the writing on the wall
for a while DT let me ask you a true or
false question is it true that Jim Ryan
said PlayStation couldn't compete
without the PlayStation having Call of
Duty uh he said it
initially maybe he he was on to
something he said it at first but then
he went back on and said no we we can't
recover if if XBox buys uh Activision
Blizzard maybe maybe the damage has been
done maybe after that PlayStation was
like we're gonna we're g we're going to
auto correct and just try to to to Glide
as much as we can down kind of like when
you playing Zelda and you make that ship
and I know Nintendo I know you can
appreciate that you make that NE that
Zelda you make that ship you flying and
you know that suck is going down but you
trying to Glide it as much as you can to
the that's maybe what maybe PlayStation
knows may maybe maybe X PlayStation is
done yeah maybe that's what they want us
to talk about dirt I know we've
completely went left and that's fine I
don't care we got one topic because
today is a cookie Nick day that's what
it is Nixie getting cooked just like
PlayStation you know niie it's fine you
already cook because you in a
PlayStation
ecosystem because when you in the oven
because that's what the PlayStation
seems to be right now an oven you
already being cooked damn you know you
that cook when I forget to get the pizza
out of the oven and it's extra black and
crispy that's what you are right
now like it's not even edible like you
sit there you look at that you put that
on the stove and you looking at that
pizza like
damn it's a
rra like like I'm upset for
you
man that's the issue man we get more
upset that these games are that that the
studio is being handled the way it is
than the actual people playing the games
that the played Studio
pleas make it make sense D look man we
should have been paying close attention
when Sean leaden got fired right we
should have been paying attention here
paid attention to some of the things
Shan leaden was saying he was saying yo
these game budget are getting out of
control they're getting out of control
and Jim Ryan came in and he didn't even
try to ease into games as the service he
just say yo not do you doing games at
the service y'all doing games just
imagine the phield Spencer went to turn
10 and say yo y'all do a firstperson
shooter games after the service like
what turn that's not what we do so so
you telling us to do a first person
shooter games as a service just because
no and you know the morale is most
definitely down then they start to hire
and and these
Acquisitions specifically for games at
the service Haven Studios was bought to
do a games as a service firewalk was
bought to do a games as a service fire
Sprite this is another Studio that we
recently heard lost 100 people they were
bought to do a games as a service even
some of their partners ship like
deviation games we know about that game
is probably canastel so you want to sit
up here and say everything is fine with
PlayStation it's not it's not bro it's
not that's why I I that's why normally I
don't entertain people trying to troll
me in the chat that's all he's doing
he's trying to troll me you ain't even
trolling me it's I'm not letting my foot
off your throat it's like you go sit
here you come in here you g to tell me I
should rotate this way rotate that way
no man we keeping it on subject yeah
what is going on at
PlayStation yep we got a bunch of super
chats man we yeah let me get these super
chats you got $5 Super Chat from the
angry therapist did Bungie lie about
their projections of Revenue I don't
know that's kind of crazy they missed
45%
45% terrible that is and we'll talk
about that here in a second we got
imagine you get 45% of your paycheck how
pissed off would you be that's half of
your paycheck that's that's a problem t
uh THX with the2 Super Chat PS Studios
padic and layoffs state of PlayStation
that's what I'm saying like there's no
okay let's let's just keep reading $5
superhot from Karen's raisin potato
salad I like that I Got a Hold the Line
and Advance the line T addict I need you
to dig into the iron Lord Vault and pull
out the sem for me bro I don't think we
we don't have spot man too because I
don't think they have codes like that
but hit me up on Twitter man I I'll
shoot you something man I'll shoot you
something uh because uh you have to show
me you have both of them though uh $2
Super Chat uh now this is a member chat
from TXS you've been a member for one
month let's talk about the state of
PlayStation that's what we talking about
buddy that's what I'm talking about this
today I don't even care I'm looking at
her feelings I'm not going to sit there
and bounce around it no we talking about
what is going on because now it's
affecting people's lives $2 Super Chat
from Blue we should sell a TTS shirt it
would sell back talk that [__] yeah man
I'm you know like me and Sean talking
about getting some merch man we trying
to figure out what to
do got some ideas though yeah $2 Super
Chat for Nintendo Don the ataku turnbas
RPG fans don't sleep on wart Tails oh
remind me after the podcast I need to
send you an advanced theine
shirt who who me yes okay um $2 super
chat if they from Blue if they had a
Resident Evil 4 it might make uh might
make better oh resistance for ain't
nobody trying to hear that though
because you know what's funny is I agree
with you blue they need to here's the
thing a console needs to be diverse it
needs to be well-rounded and Playstation
for like a decade didn't do anything in
that realm that's what they're hurting
with now you know in in some ways Jim
Ryan wasn't wrong they need to do better
in that area but Jim Ryan here's the
thing Phil took longer Phil was like
look we need to improve in multiple
areas it's gonna take a long time to do
these out areas so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do it step by
step Jim Ryan was like abandon that ship
and get on this ship Jim Ryan tried to
do everything at the same time yo that's
everybody focus on games as the service
and that's just not know five out super
chat from God ERS suffer King uh INX is
in here dude blocked me because I made
fun of his Cheeto dust federa wearing
loser TTS Rest in Piss Pony
what oh like you guys are ridiculous $5
Super Chat for the angry therapist
mismanagement of funds wasted money
blocking gains from Xbox because of uh
part of this now here's the thing okay I
don't
think I don't know it probably did cost
them more money to block games for Game
Pass why would a studio sign a
contract with the same type of marketing
that they've always done and prevent
them from putting on gay pass I would
say you're right they probably did spend
a lot of money blocking that because if
you here's the thing if I come up to you
and I'm like Call of Duty this is what
we've always done here is the agreement
sign it same thing probably same price
but if I came up to you Dart and I was
like you on the atct show you can't go
on nothing else
that's going to be a different
conversation yeah I'm like what I'm like
how much you paying pay me for my
exclusivity $2 super from John TJ
blowing into a controller is blowing oh
whoa who
whoa PG over here T THX
1138 42 million ps5s and only 2.5
million Spider-Man 2os uh I'm going to
say it's still good uh you know I do
agree with you I think it should have
been better because I feel like
Spider-Man is a different brand than
normal there should have been more
people that bought it but I'm still
going to come out and say 2.5 in a day
is still really good yeah but I do agree
with you that that's a huge brand just
for that uh $20 Super Chat uh ja 82 I am
so sick of these guys who want to stick
it to Xbox but talking about PlayStation
is wrong Sony is in trouble no road map
firing people who been there 30 plus
years Prince ran for the heels keep up
the good workout he right you know that
that that's that's where I'm really
staying yeah fire like they said some of
the uh like high ups and fire sprik got
the money left that that that's my
biggest issue wow isn't the fact that
PlayStation people are talking about
Xbox it's their zero accountability 100%
they always want to put a magnifying
glass and I told you I'm done with it
this isn't the iron Lords podcast I'm
calling you out might as well put a big
ass adct show logo in the sky right
now I'm not we ain't the people that you
deserve we the people you needed there
you go we got a $2 from Gerald Mack is
it enough for Sony to rep pivot and
recover yes they can repot recover but
you guys don't realize I I I truly
believe Ryan is going to be compared to
Dawn matrick in a lot of way oh 100%
because Addy like before you go to the
next Super Chat let me say this right
quick I say all the time Phil Spencer
had to rebuild the Xbox brand after Don
matrick left he had to re and it took
time guess what's going to happen
PlayStation fans whoever is the next CEO
of PlayStation they're gonna have to
rebuild the brand they're gonna have to
figure out a way to still remain the
market leader I know console sales are
great but they don't have their Cash Cow
and Call of Duty is I mean they still
have it but they don't have it anymore
if you know what I mean so they have to
figure out a way to rep pivot and like
you said J M recover because they have
to get back on track and it's Gonna Take
Years it's gonna Xbox year and
especially if these games don't do
well that it it I'm gonna be real with
you it might be one of those things that
they never recover from like obviously
they'll probably get back on track but
will they recover Xbox got back on track
from the Xbox one generation but they
have never truly recovered from it but
also one thing Microsoft is behind Xbox
they got the money Sony doesn't have it
like that Sony if you think about Sega
when when the PS2 was just destroying
Dreamcast Sega couldn't recover because
they didn't have the finances Xbox
recover because they had Microsoft
behind them who the only
have nothing those are question
oh all right so let's get to this next
$10 Super Chat from good Rich Gamers uh
the game industry is getting hard hit
hard we lost about 7,000 job this year
and we have two months to go I haven't
seen it this bad since
2008 uh when we lost mid tier uh
mid-tier doublea Studios back then yeah
that's true 100% right man and and I
think that's part of the thing that
irritates me the most is and this is
everyone even Xbox lays people off but
part that irritates me the most is
incompetence on a leadership on an
executive letter on multiple levels from
Sony to Bungie and all these people are
losing their livelihood and you got
these Sony Fanboys trying to justify
that
[__] yeah it's rough
man good Super Chat Go game $2 Super
Chat from uh Karen's raisin potato salad
I did tag you and King a week ago okay
uh send me a me tag me again and uh
after the show because I probably won't
see it I'll probably get on to like 20
plus notifications again after the show
$5 shoot for Nintendo Don theotaku fire
spot was made of Sony Liverpool devs a
studio that Sony closed and they joined
Sony again just to be on the verge of
closure again man that's terrible bro I
mean listen I always say like before I'm
SP gamer I'm a gamer and I want the
industry to remain healthy and to seeing
all these layoffs is you know I mean
like we have fun and talk trash but at
the end of the day you know I don't like
it
man remain healthy here here's the thing
at the end of the
day if the industry doesn't I'm not even
damned everything
else how are we gonna see better Talent
come into the industry with the
conditions that the industry is in now
this is not even this is the industry is
in ho how is
epic epic laying people off yeah it's
rough man that is mindblowing to me so
the person that would come into the
industry that's in school right now that
could potentially make the next engine
that runs the next generation of games
or make make the next fortnite that's
sitting there in school right now
looking at the industry right now like
like no [__]
that he's like why would you there's no
job security in this industry right now
yeah there's definitely not unless they
start the union stuff man unless they
really do
unions all right we got $2 Super Chat
from Sarah Evans market leader game
selling still not enough I it's not
necessarily a market lead here at one
point in
time you
know uh what's that place called I
forgot um Blockbuster was on top 100%
And if you look because King King show
line on that I didn't realize there's
not a lot of time when Blockbuster was
on top till they were not anywhere bro
it was like a few few years it seemed
like they were up here next thing you
know they gone man like damn what
happened $2 Super Chat from poge Bravo
marathon is garbage they should have
made Destiny 3 all completely agree
that's a completely different
conversation we do have a topic I want
to talk about and breaking more of the
PlayStation stuff because I have to be
out of here by like
6:30ish sevenish because I actually have
something um I'm testing I can't talk to
about it because it's under NDA but I do
have to be out of here so uh we will get
into that here in a
minute five out super chat from Jake the
gaming truck trucker they should have to
ask bring back old IPS instead of doing
remakes of games that are three years
old it's just play the three game uh the
threee old games they hurt themselves
and see here's the thing but Jay you
know what's an easier sell an IP or
something that people already know and a
lot of these people they're okay with
that you know that's one another one of
the issues you know there's a reason you
see the Xbox community in constant Civil
War CU we never agree on
anything on what Xbox is doing right or
what Xbox is doing wrong you don't see
PlayStation Community going at each
other because they're all a hive
M I'm on my [__] today I don't care oh
yeah I'm loving it man dir addict uh he
$5 experience from slow-mo backslash
addict offer a trade dirt on DPS and set
a addict show for a box
full of PS portals won't be missed in
get Forte's GameStop I open negotiations
oh man nah man P I'm sure if you hit
that's all I'm worth yeah I'm sure if
you hit up dirt He he'll show up as a
guest for week ask me man yeah I'm
sure oh you do your stuff do my too but
I think theirs is after my show though
yeah just talk to him man talk to
him $2 Super Chat from uh Jamal Mar Le
PS PS out Sony PS in trouble Sony in
trouble yeah we got a $2 from Nintendo
Dawn the otaku how many layoffs y'all
heard of Nintendo Nintendo lays people
off but I will say it does seem like
Nintendo if they do have a bad quarter
they take a lot of that to the face
pause uh it does look like they're
willing to understand that sometimes a
quarter is just a bad quarter and they
realize that you know I feel like
Nintendo's more realistic with scenarios
they're like we didn't release any huge
Gamers this quarter so we understand why
we didn't get that growth but we're not
going to punish the people who make the
games for
it hey but let's be real that damn
Nintendo Wii helped the Nintendo brand
because they they might have been third
party if that Wii would have
failed or the Wii I'm soring not the Wii
to switch because that Wii U was a
disaster
all right so we got $2 for angry
therapist Xbox is more Forward Thinking
the PlayStation they've always been more
forward thinking but I will say uh
Playstation because of they had the
whole play here's the thing they had the
whole PlayStation 4 to get their their
their row in a tuck and they were able
to get a lot of these Studios
self-sufficient and they were and their
very talented Studios but as you can see
none of that matters when you don't care
about what they're saying yeah when you
have Studios coming out there and just
telling you yo we don't want to go this
pivot you're buying all these Studios
make them make that game we have proven
ourselves 100% why are you making us do
it how can you tell naughty dog to do a
multiplayer only game bro I would say
they are in my opinion they are the best
right next to Rockstar at making single
player story driven game and you tell
them do a multiplayer $5 Super Chat from
cobweb uh
cobweb Blackberry outs Soo the original
iPhone and iPhone 3DS 3:1 how that help
Blackberry in the long run they exist
but barely you have to evolve he's got
huge point right there 100% then we got
a$2 strap from uh kindan Hardy yeah
that's what L like keep cooking I'm GNA
cook that I'm a this I'm a cook all
right appreciate appreciate all the love
man appr the love all right so let let's
let's get into this four this first
crazy stuff that's happening all right
so Bungie okay I don't know how to go
about the Bungie thing uh we're gonna
start the Bungie thing at 43
[Music]
minutes so bu is having these crazy
layoffs and things don't make sense for
Bungie um they have went
from they laid off like eight% of the
company there's a lot of people working
for
Bungie employees or something right yeah
so there's a lot they and to
me I don't know if PlayStation's
involved in this or they're not involved
in this come on you know come listen
they got something to do with it so I
think that they
probably told Bungie you didn't hit your
quotes you got to cut people but I think
Bungie targeted the people that were
going to make money off of them because
they were sold so they could keep that
money that's the way it looks to me
that's not that's a great Point yeah so
I think that's probably how it went
PlayStation and even though we we clown
on Playstation especially what they be
doing if if if you spent that kind of
money on if if you spent that kind of
money on
Playstation you do I mean on Bungie you
do kind of expect some returns so I I
don't blame Bungie uh for for
PlayStation like yo why you
45% percent off projections for for
money that's crazy
45% that's a lot man it you know I guess
you can make the argument that you
know maybe you shouldn't have laid
people off but here's the thing
PlayStation did put them in that
position where they're like you we got
to let some people
go why did Bungie pick the people they
picked and another
question why is PlayStation letting them
go this
Direction that's some good questions I
do agree what you said I believe Sony
was like look man y'all got to do
something and they and like Bungie chose
the people for whatever reason I heard
that um man there a lot of stuff I don't
even have in front of me right now but a
lot of crazy stuff with Bungie man and
the employees that they let
go um man I I you know I feel bad for
those people you know it's a part of the
gaming industry you know we see layups
all the time but at the end of the day
like 40 missing so like the 45% thing is
what they uh they thought they were
going to have a certain amount of of
profit or Revenue but it's 45%
less that's
abysmal like I said imagine you go to
work and your paycheck is 45% less I'm
walking right back in the
building bro it's gonna be some problems
yo yo yo 45% Less on your paycheck that
you was expecting to get from Bungie
it's gonna be one of those things where
you walking out with the paper paycheck
and you literally doing this in the
middle of looking at it yeah look you're
just turning right back around walking
right back in that room what's this this
GNA be some problem now Mike Johnson I
understand this it's cool to be
optimistic about the future but you
can't just say everything is going to be
fine there are some things that's going
to be done because if okay so we're
hearing that they're going to focus on
not Acquisitions but third party
Partnerships because they're not going
to have anything first party ready in a
couple years guys I got to be real
they're talking about going back on
their games as a service so what about
the games that's been in development
what about
Haven like fire Sprite firew walk walk
what about these Studios they bought
four games as a service what are they
gonna do with those Studios Bungie what
is going to happen so you can't just sit
here and say everything is g to be fine
no you do make a good point if they
pivot away from the games of service
entirely I'm curious that they start
either dismantling Studios yeah or just
selling them back it's like it's like a
fire sell it's like Bungie we bought you
for two .5 billion was will give you
your Independence for a billion give us
some of that money back yeah I mean
that's what it seems like so there's
always concern like okay remember when a
lot of people was bringing up stuff
about Xbox and
343 I remember us talking about the
attic on on this show there were a lot
of changes being made at 343 so
sometimes when there's smoke there's
fire right we can talk about it some
fans might say no everything is fine
some Xbox fans say everything is fine
but obiously not because they made some
management changes at 343 and now
they're thriving right now they're
looking really good so some things are
changing at PlayStation I'm not saying
PlayStation is dead I'm not saying
they're dying I'm just saying there are
some changes being made and some of you
PlayStation Fanboys might want to open
your
eyes and pay attention to what's going
on don't just automatically assume
everything is going to be fine me I was
a Sega fan I just automatically assume
assumed everything was going to be fine
until they came out and said we are no
longer supporting the Dreamcast we're
going to be a third
party like I said the difference between
Microsoft and some of these other other
companies is Xbox had Microsoft behind
them and we know Microsoft was one of
the richest companies in the world Sega
didn't have anybody Sony doesn't have
anybody so you guys be very careful and
pay close
attention Sony is still the more popular
brand you know that mean everything is
great people don't realize there's
there's worse scenarios than they think
there's scenarios where the PlayStation
brand doesn't help keep the
Sony brand from collapsing anymore yeah
and then they have to sell to like an
apple why you wake up one day to Apple
buying
PlayStation and and then imagine where
this conversation's going I think
that'll be great for them because
they'll be they'll be able to compete
financially with with uh they'll be able
to compete financially but is Apple
going to compete that type of way that's
a go crazy because because all they
could do is like yo we make all this
money off of mobile games right and then
their mindsets like what you making is
pennies off of what we making you're do
wrong you're right about that ad you're
right add you're right about that and
you know what some let me give let let
me say something about Xbox like before
before we move on Xbox has their hands
in mobile
now they have their hands in games as a
service um Minecraft is still one of the
best games best selling games every
month now they have Call of Duty under
their belt um they have some amazing
games as the service so they like like
have great services like Xbox game pass
and things of that nature so Xbox is
putting themselves in a position where
they're going to be successful and if
you want to play an Xbox game you can
play it on PC Mobile wherever with
PlayStation you can only play it on the
PS5 console unless you want to wait two
years for it to be on PC so these are
things PlayStation should have dabbled
into trying to do mobile they should
have dabbled and putting their games on
PC earlier and they should have dabbled
in games as a service when it was really
hot so see here's my thing when it comes
with this man it's like why can't we
just call companies
out you know
even the what what I find is funny is
when you and people went at it last week
and they called you like an echo chamber
even even the echo chamber that dirt
built he still calls Xbox
out like here's the
thing I do think think that people get
this weird misconception with you you
better an echo chamber because you're
tired of hearing dumbass takes and I
don't yeah ponies that there yeah it has
nothing to do with all of wanting to to
be positive about Xbox 247 they just got
tired hearing about dumbass takes on
Xbox for no reason kind of like my uh
you know my superhero thing he thinks
it's a dumbass
take it's like look like we can still
like Kingdom Hearts one of my favorite
friends es I flamed Kingdom Hearts 3
Final Fantasy one of my favorite
franchises I flamed Final Fantasy
16 Fable is my alltime one of my
favorite franchises and you damn right
I'mma flame them if they do if they mess
up if it's not great
right it's like you be they supposed to
be working for us not the other way
around some of you in the chat you be
working for them
and you ain't getting
paid at least when you look at something
like like influencers at least we get
some kind of conversation for
it it's like some of you be on Twitter
all
day talking to
yourself let
Meats $ five Super Chat from Kendrick
Hardy by the way it's me fzy fzy or fzy
fzy fzy I called it is going to Game of
Thrones us called it when the light uh
the lightf trailer drops we'll see I'm
kind of curious on that we'll see though
from Vic the [__] click the ying and
yang podcast uh world of the podcast
world yeah what's up I love I love how
they always they pick everything that's
white and
black look what the light and darkness
podcast yeah ebony ivory
mashed potatoes and gravy someone said
mashed potatoes and gravy no that was me
that made that oh it's like uh got a $2
Super Chat from txx 11138 Sony acquired
Bungie for
3.7 billion to retain time yeah what
happened with that oh me call us the the
dudly boys you know the dudly boys are
uh R WWF yeah that's funny um yeah what
happened with that they they put a
billion aside for retention to retain
employees I guess that's that didn't
work right unless you know this is just
this is just like 10 full hat moments
unless they've pivoted yeah and they're
like we no longer care about that
future how many of those people can you
get rid of so we don't have to pay that
yeah I I'm kind of curious damn that's
crazy paid that 3.4 bill because I don't
know how this stuff works right like if
they're not there for that x amount of
time does that mean Sony just keeps the
money or does it go some to someone
that's a valid question I have no idea
bro so someone put in the com how much
was just for retention in the comment
section just the retention was like 1.4
billion how much was just the
retention to keep this the the the the
Budgy
employees because like here look you
know when you look at something like you
know even even 40 I personally feel like
you shouldn't be losing your job in any
industry unless you're consistently hit
missing
marks missing one Mark should not make
you lose 8% of your
staff but that's not the way the
corporate world works
you know because to
me you could always
rebound and fix tip but if you lose the
people that could potentially fix it
what's the
point yeah and that that's why I don't
like Corporate America I hate the [__]
because it's just like they never give
enough time to fix anything it's always
you fix it now or we'll find other
people most of the time people think
it's grass on the other side uh the
grass is greener on the other no most of
the time it's it it the grass on the
other side is dirt it ain't even grass
no no pun attended hey so Nintendo onaku
said it said yeah 1.2 billion from the
article so my curiosity you know and I
don't think this happened but let's say
PlayStation sat down and they're like
legally because they let's say that
their mindset is like we're no longer
wanting this direction this is the way
that this is this is Jim Ryan's future
this is not the future anymore they're
like can we get some of this money back
I'm curious on that like did that money
go to
Bungie all of it and Bungie was just
holding on to it because if Bungie owned
it because the retention was 1.2 billion
so is that given when the retention is
up and they're able because here's the
thing do they does Sony keep that 1.2
billion if the people that was going to
get that money just ironically don't
work there anymore after the duration
yeah that's a valid question I I saw Mr
Orange um said that Apple can't buy Sony
I would like to see why he said that um
but well that was an earlier
comment it's
just okay so he said it couldn't if you
missed
45% of your sales in in a result of the
layoffs that's shitty but I guess that's
how the corporate industry Works MH but
if if you if they did these
layoffs to rob people of the money that
they had for their shares and raw people
of shares so they couldn't cash them
out that's grimy that's dirty that
should be
legal and I wouldn't be surprised if a
class action lawsuit is put on bung
and Sony for you'll be kind of crazy in
the next year Bungie splits off from
Sony yeah I think is inevitable I think
it's probably going to happen um so Mr
Orin said uh Apple buying Sony would be
a horizontal merger and um that would be
very difficult to do so but he said you
know then he said they're possible but
they will yeah okay but it'll be very
difficult to do okay cool thanks I I
didn't realize that you know I don't
know nothing about this stuff I don't
either we just like the most I've
learned was doing this ABK acquisition
okay so we Johnson said the money was
sent to senior leadership the problem is
is they're getting a they're getting rid
of some of that senior
leadership uh people that's been there
for decades are getting let go for no
reason damn just like you know like
Honey Boo
man she was a producer for 34 years at
PlayStation man it just it irritates
because stuff like this is never going
to help the industry it's always going
to hurt it doesn't matter what happens
stuff like this is always going to hurt
the industry and then people wonder why
you have the
industry like really pushing back trying
to get a better life for themselves it's
like and then they're like well we need
to
get we need to get um
you know uh unions and stuff it's like
why do you expect these companies not to
fight for
unions when you gave them years of your
life and what did it turn out to it
turned out to we're gonna lay you off
and give you the rest of the day to
claim any benefits that's not MediCal
that's crazy bro $2 Super Chat from Blue
uh
HW how many months till Xbox Buy PS IPS
to help pay
bills yo what I I don't think that'll
ever happen What happens if XBox has to
do to the PlayStation thing that that
Microsoft had to do to
Apple well you know what I was um
schooled on this topic they said they
literally gave Apple I forget how much
money but they gave it to them because I
guess The Regulators were saying that um
Microsoft has a monopoly and they gave
apples some money to say no no we're not
a monopoly they're they're a competitor
or something like that I could be wrong
the way I put it but yeah but they
definitely gave him some money and then
of course
Apple they blew up two from Jonas to Dad
to sell Sony with split PS Hardware
movies TV agreed agreed on that I agreed
on that all right so let's let's get to
our last topic
Man Xbox will sell
Xbox we going we going to talk about
PlayStation on
fire uh we were going to talk about the
Insomniac thing but we're just gonna
merge them together yeah yeah it's all
the same stuff yeah so first let's talk
about
Insomniac it's reported today I don't
know if it's been confirmed maybe you
could tell me did Snick really suffer
from layoffs it hasn't been confirmed as
far as any media Outlet I've seen so far
uh I haven't seen But the report came
from um I guess was it a hold on let me
see it was a uh was it a
lining what was
it I I don't know where it's at damn I
don't know where it's at maybe lost it I
don't know but I guess it was from some
type of um some employee of Insomniac
said that yeah uh I've been laid off
today so you know we can't verify it yet
but it does seem like it's true well
maybe so I'm going say one thing look
you know meet a molecule you know some
of the other Studios that haven't really
generated probably a lot of income for
for Sony as much as I hate it you know
that would make more sense than
Insomniac yeah PlayStation feel
shamed if they if they if they laid off
one person from Insomniac bro Insomniac
has been there Brad and
Butler it's something that has been
their Workhorse this generation I just
sent you an article that says it um
arguably the only company that is
keeping them
afloat
yeah yeah so it does look like there are
people confirming that they
have been let go but we won't really
talk in in definite terms it's like look
if this happen this is pathetic I'm
gonna be real like I I even understand
you
know like Naughty Dog they kind of drop
the ball when it come to to to faction
so that makes a little bit more sense
than him sonc and if you want to get
technical dirt even Naughty Dog
shouldn't have suffered from from
layoffs like they literally just made
you all this money from The Last of Us
Part Two m
you pushed them more towards factions
than it seemed like them pushing them
themselves towards
factions why why would you lay people
off in that field
man world is rough man they just made
them what they saw 2.5 Bill 2.5 million
copies in in 24 hours of Spider-Man 2 it
imagine those developers when they saw
those numbers was like we
safe we we we did what we were supposed
to imagine
getting getting rewarded for your good
stuff for the making this company all
these billions and millions of dollars
it's like here's a pink slit it's
pathetic I don't understand how the
industry is going to keep operating this
way yeah how do I win one of the most
[__] most Financial years in gaming D
but we've also had one of the biggest
layoffs in the industry and I think a
lot of that's probably like excessive
fat that they consider from like the
pandemic but it's just like I get it but
I don't get it at the same
time yeah it's it's a rough time and um
I just hope that you know I have a bad
feeling that because the state of the
industry unless you have a for sure bet
like a GTA or even a Spider-Man or Call
of Duty I really feel we're going to get
less um gambles you know like we're
going to get like more remakes of a more
sequels we're going to get less new IPS
because some of these companies are not
going to want to gamble on it now Xbox
can gamble because they have a Xbox game
pass they can do certain stuff like that
because of Xbox game pass but some of
these other third party companies like
look at Ubisoft Assassin's Creed Mirage
I haven't played it yet I have it but
that one is way way uh down like uh way
smaller game than their previous three
Assassin Creed games were because they
don't want to spend all that money in
and they don't get their money back so I
believe we will see more quality double
A games or smaller scale games maybe
games that's not like uh like Assassin's
Creed Val holla that game was too long
like 80 hour games maybe these games
might be just a 20 hour game I really
believe that's going to happen and I
don't know if you saw you hearing all
this stuff about PlayStation about to
drop a God of War
DLC it's a DLC why isn't it a sequel a
full Flair sequel because I think we're
going to start to see that there's like
the rumor is it might be on a scale of a
Miles
Morales I mean that should tell you
right there they if the game is still
going to be great AAA quality it's not
going to be as long so uh and it's not
just Sony I believe a lot of companies
are going the same way so that's what
I'm afraid of it's
just I get generally annoyed I really do
and I know I shouldn't get dis annoyed
from this but I said Miles Morales I a
say Mike Morales did I say Mike
Morales yeah I I guess part of me is
just like where do these people think
that they were going you know what I'm
saying like it's
like I just don't understand how this Co
this
industry thinks they're going to keep
going the way they're going
like to
me if you're going to
consistently treat the people who make
these
games this
bad you're gonna eventually get to the
point where no one's going to want to
work in this industry you're never going
to get to a point where you have new
blood popping in because like why would
they they can go to any other industry
that treats their people that make these
these products better than the way we
have now that's why I don't understand
when people say that like layoffs look
like do layoffs affect me no but it
affects the industry which affects you
indirectly absolutely and it affects us
because we're
Gamers we're Gamers yeah so it
definitely affects us oh I agree you
know Nixie
uh it is the Publishers 100% the
Publishers all of them greedy bastards
all of them and it's just like I just
get so annoyed DT where it's like making
billions of dollars a pro profit isn't
enough
anymore it's right it's not enough right
yeah got to make a billion in one point
right hey Manan some of the people are
saying every game doesn't need to be 50
hours I agree with that because I felt
Assassin's Creed Valla V the game was
great it was too damn long um yeah I Dro
game doesn't need to be that long bro I
dropped before I even found it out it
was when I found out it was that long I
dropped it yeah and you know with me
because I was doing something wrong I
got like about 170 hours in that game it
doesn't take that long to finish but I
it was crazy so yeah that game games
doesn't need to be that long I just I
guess to me man I just especially this
year I I've just got so at this point
it's just so cold you know what I'm
saying it's like it's like especially
epic epic is the worst offenders for
this because the amount of money that
they make off of
fortnite they probably spent more money
to license one of these skins that they
make in this game that would have cost
to keep all they people on for three or
four years that's crazy that's CRA you
mean to tell me that you value the and I
get it these skins make you money all
this I get it and I get it people saying
it's capitalism but that's not good
enough for me because where does it
end
yep did you see people are uh are mass
pulling out
of of pre-orders of of the of the last
expansion for Destiny I did see that
yeah I saw an article about that earlier
yeah I did and right there with you you
know I
unfortunately I probably will still pick
it up but I do highly recommend you know
don't buy this [__] till it's out you
don't have to don't pre-order and show
them these
numbers let them
sweat let them think they about to
flop because it's like and guess what I
will say for one on mean I'm so invested
I don't know if I can just sit it out
I'm gonna be honest right but after the
final shape I'm done with Destiny and
and you know
I've been a long time Destiny player for
like 10
years yeah so it's just like and yeah
I'm being I'm definitely being
hypocritical 100% definitely being
hypocritical but here's the thing here's
the thing all right let me let me pin
you because you ain't wrong I'm a
hypocritical [__] but here's the thing
serve I'm being honest about it okay uh
I have put too much time
in a destiny not to to live this last
expansion so I'm looking at all you
other people I need you to pick up my
slack all right but I'll say right now I
won't pre-order
it I I I'll make them think my money
ain't
coming it'll come late but it'll be
there how many hours do you have I have
over like 3,000 hours in Destiny yeah
you definitely a destiny player goodness
and what's funny is I'm like 50 50th of
my friends list when it comes to how
what yeah it's when it comes to time
it's ridiculous
damn yeah it's it's ridiculous man
here's the thing poking claims
247 I've always
said
I
am weak when it comes to my
stuff all right my name is gaming addict
do you think I'm just not gonna play a
game like look if it was anything else
guys maybe Fable I'd probably I I
probably step the line for fael too I'm
I'm gonna be real with you guys lover
guy says he has 9,000 hours goodness man
yes kid we are
live if it was anything
else I would be right there with you in
that picking line I'll be there with you
okay I'll be doing the picket line going
down the we hell no we won't go but the
moment the game launches I'm G have to
put my picket down and sneak past that
into the building
okay yo the way I see it if you guys
refuse to
play then guess what it'll be easier for
me to get in day
one cuz dude the the servers Get
Ridiculous the same day it comes out
like you ain't even playing Destiny that
first day it's like look I'm just going
to be honest with you guys like I want
everything in me I can sit here and I
could tell you guys boycott but I know
for a fact I'm not gonna have that
energy I know I'm not gonna I'mma sit
there I'mma I'mma pull an anchor man V
I'mma hide offline and
play so I'm not GNA even hide offline
I'mma say my my foolishness and I'm say
my contradicting ass right
now oh my god there you have it y'all
there you have it would you would you
boycott your favorite
game um it depends on what they did your
favorite game I I'll probably be like
like I'll be mad at it for a week or two
then I say let me goad and give a
try PE people sitting here people
sitting here coming at me acting like
they ain't try to boy eight G you know
adct that's like when your wife piss you
off and and you try to act mad at her
but then she walk walk past you like n
or something like damn or like with some
booty shorts on you're like damn be mad
at it much longer people G sit here you
could come at me man you can you you can
make memes about me that's fine cause
because I know without a doubt I'm weak
when it comes to games there you I know
I'm not gonna do it I know I'mma sit
here I'mma say all day long I ain't
playing that but when it comes down to
what's your favorite franchise DT oh man
your favorite one that when it comes out
you just hype you can't wait to play
that [__] what's your favorite FR um I
I'm like that with 2K um okay besides
2K because I feel like you I feel like
you don't have that energy for 2K so I
got to do something else yeah man the
Pay to Win model kind of irritated me
with 2K uh
there's so many games man um what about
hellblade you looking forward to
hellblade hell yeah definitely looking
forward to hellblade see here's the
thing gears gears so gear six pops out
yeah and I gota play that this happen
something similar like this happens
Microsoft lays off all the Coalition
people you're not playing I'll be I'll
do a podcast like this is some
BS I can't live after the show you go
buy it but I got to see though how how
it looks though hey hey dirt I know what
you want I know what you your out is
well it's in Game
Pass I didn't buy it yeah look man I I
feel you guys I do I do and and it's
like I said I support the boycotting
movement I just myself ain't going to
participate I I don't I don't spend
microtransactions I don't really give
them any money besides that initial $100
a
year hey man hey like way Johnson said
he would never boycott n gay nor
Resident Evil ain't happening so so they
they got us they got us by the balls
yeah like it's our it's our passion like
it's like you know I will say that there
is limits there are certain things that
people companies can do that I would not
support whatsoever but it would have to
be some likey it have to be some like
War crime [__] like you gotta be
something really bad it would have to be
something like the whole studio did yeah
because I'mma say well I'mma support the
people that didn't do some dumb [__]
like
man these super chats Alvin it's silly
man I'll read them before even want me
to yeah yeah yes yes put him up for me
just put him out there Jonas the Dad
what's up homie with who to sell Sony
was split PlayStation Hardware movies TV
yeah I can see that I can definitely see
that kendri kendria Hardy with the two
kendrian Hardley if Sony sells they lose
Spider-Man just
saying that's that's a valid point Paul
go Bravo with the two I have 10K and I
quit hypocrite oh damn you talk about
you
Al you got 10,000 hours goodness
yeah you know what's funny
uh R Randy I with to fight all Randy
pitchmark could
sort read that I ain't read that Randy P
could snort dust off 100 Biden's chest
and I'm still pre-ordering Borderlands 4
oh my God Alva you crazy
bro I didn't realize this uh my my aunt
she she comes over here because she
don't have like uh she don't have like a
bank card or anything she she hands me
this she hands me this this year it's
like $42 okay she's like can you can you
buy me currency and Candy Crush I didn't
know this was going down like this hey
man that's Xbox first party you got to
get it for man go the Google Play card
like she got Android or iPhone I just I
just buy it off my uh PayPal account
okay okay yeah because my mother-in-law
was playing some game on her Android I
didn't know it took money like this bro
I listen man it's a free to play but you
can only play uh let it give you five
turns right if you if you fail five
times you gotta wait you gotta wait for
your your your turns to replenish and it
takes some time so if you wanted to
hurry up you go ahead and spend some
real money on it man my brother got me
flowers oh ain't that
sweet take take take your flow
hey that's sweet man that's brotherly
love right there yeah Candy Crush I mean
they don't charge to play but when
you're addicted to it you're playing it
like I said if you want to you know
speed stuff up if you want some more
more turns you gotta you know you can
either wait or you can just go ahead and
spend some money for extra you know the
powerups and stuff yeah man they get you
they get you brother why you think can
make so much money because it's a free
to play you know it just when it comes
down to it man
it's
like we I just want the industry to do
better I got a lot of Dev friends and
you know I want to get into the industry
I I want to be a community manager I you
know behind closed doors I've been doing
interviews for certain things and it's
just
like this affects me why do I get into
an industry and I'm stupid I'm stupid at
this point I it's it's like it's like I
I'm literally walking up to something
and just stabbing myself in the eye it's
like it might not hurt me now it's G
hurt me later it's just it's frustrating
man it's generally
frustrating and it's nothing you could
do about it it really is nothing you
could do about it because you know the
the way the industry goes you can't stop
it y it is what it is
brother all right so let's go ahead and
uh let's go ahead and start closing this
up man uh
look uh the the the individual that uh I
I already forgot his name oh Nixie there
you are Nixie I got no issue with you
man I got this a all jokes yeah but see
here's the thing I don't mind the
PlayStation people that take the joke
well you've been in this chat you didn't
get disrespectful so you know uh it is
what it is all that and it's just some
of you be just being too much you know
uh
and that is what it is all right so Dirk
where the people find you at I
see chat um check out my channel DK
griggy uh you know I talk a lot of trash
have a lot of fun I do console war stuff
so don't expect me to gonna be fair U no
I am Fair yeah okay um anyway yeah so
check out my channel
um I call I call dirt the second line
you know K kings on that front line and
dirt's in the back with the arrows just
shooting the kneecaps out of PlayStation
for yeah we you know had a lot of fun I
got a podcast my one man dark man
podcast tomorrow night tomorrow evening
at 6:00 pm eastern time I'm gonna listen
I'm gonna be talking a lot of trash we
didn't we talked a little trash over
here but we gonna talk a lot of trash on
my show tomorrow yeah your show on
Monday night be be crazy some yeah they
do man
like Sean are you guys started going
like because I I usually listen to you
late and uh after the podcast and I'll
listen to you uh like while I'm playing
Persona or something I play I listen to
like three weeks of you guys in a row
when I play Persona 5 oh um do do you
guys do camera fulltime now or is that
just like well uh I don't know that one
time thing for King King when we when
like King told you know like let King we
got know we got put our cameras on so
then we did it I did it the week after
just me but this week everybody had
their camera on so I'm not sure some of
the fellas they don't be want to be on
the camera like me I don't care you know
but like sh be like 12 and I'm sorry to
interrupt you I gotta show the chat this
yo um I'm gonna show who just tweet
tweeted me and dirt go go to Twitter
because uh we're about to show this yo
you you a Savage for this you a Savage
for this cuz I ain't I ain't this
good damn bro dude this is said 372 days
well and he doesn't even have all the
gamer score let me do the
math
372 days damn shout out to him man
because I'm telling you like that game
is addicting people don't understand how
addicting Destiny is at its core its
issues hours that's like $9,000 hours
bro that's crazy it's issues close to
close that's why part of me is lowkey
glad that this is over this is
done it's like and I won't I refuse to
put myself in this position again I'mma
Be real part of me is hoping that they
never catch back up and they never you
know they they they move on to Marathon
because I know I don't give two shits
about Marathon CU because I'm like I see
a future that I'm not connected to
Destiny and I'm so glad and I'm like
please don't pick this up
please just let it go Bungie because if
they come out with some fire story and
they start doing the game
right I'm back and I don't like it I
don't like knowing that I don't like KN
that you got uh I don't know what
currency I'm not sure what currency that
is oh is that Yan I believe that's Yan
1,000 yen Japanese currency I believe
yeah I love to see what Yen looks like
someone are someone so someone tweet me
what Yin looks like uh being fair to
Sony fans cost them one CoD game uh Cod
copy on
PS5 it's interesting man it's
interesting you know I want to
appreciate every for coming through
we're gonna go ahead and close out of
here I gotta test this game here in a
minute I literally went from doing the
spoilercast on Spider-Man 2 of King then
I went to this back to back and then I
went to this on the attic show and I'm
gonna play for two hours on a game that
I have not allow to talk about I'm
exhausted and then probably after that
my girl's gonna be home and she's gonna
want to make dinner there you go man you
get your night plan brother yeah so let
me see where we're gonna send you guys
love yeah what's up man yeah that's how
I know it was y you know you usually
tweet Yan in from Japan
so where are we sing these people where
we sing them fame fame on T night
uh he's on but he's not on yet uh I'm
gonna send you guys over there I don't
got time uh to to wait for him to come
on uh he will be going live in like two
minutes get you guys sit down get
something to eat get something to drink
yeah I'm sure f be extra extra over
there too I'm sure he gonna be extra no
I'm not testing Marathon I'm sure he GNA
be extra extra over there too but once
again I want to appreciate everyone
coming through it was it was fun
experience with everyone and until next
time this is G me addict and dark G we
peace
out